pointe-à-callière propose un regard
historique mais aussi ludique et
technologiques sur le monde ferroviaire
sous toutes ses formes avec très
transporteurs de rêve le rêve du train
comme jouer comme objets de collection
comme objet pour les créateurs dans dans
leurs films dans la littérature puis
aussi comme agent de développement plus
de 1000 objets nous permettent de
constater le rôle crucial du trait dans
la création du pays notamment la
colombie britannique qui a accepté de
faire partie de la confédération
canadienne inconditionnellement ce que
le train se rendent jusque là à l'époque
où montréal était la métropole du canada
la ville a été façonné par l'industrie
ferroviaire dans le développement de
montréal ils vont être cruciales dans
développement commercial mondial va
devenir la grande métropole et grâce au
train va pouvoir exporter ces denrées si
aussi au train qu'on doit la naissance
du tourisme au pays et même la création
de cilicie radio canada chaque grandes
compagnies canadiennes on parle du cn on
parle du cp va développer autour de
autour du dren donc de grands hôtels qui
vont être des stations où les visiteurs
vont pouvoir s'arrêter passer quelques
jours avant de retourner dans le train
de poursuivre leur route aussi
l'initiateur de divertissement de la
radio donc d'un un sens de radio canada
puisque des jusqu'à l'intérieur des
trains les propriétaires vont se
demander comment on peut faire pour
divertir notre public qui vont donc
installé créer une pro leur propre radio
le très facile du petits et les grands
l'exposition présente des centaines de
jouets de collection
le train arrive en angleterre vers 1830
pas longtemps après il ya tout les
commerces des jouets qui se développe
premier rappel pour les passagers des
récits par une visite virtuelle en
compagnie de guides animateurs
embarquement le dimanche 13 décembre à
13h30 sur le site internet de pointe à
callière ici des billets alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal
non